hey David does a lotta discussion about
taxes wealth tax capital gains tax
income tax question can you just tell us
what you think the top marginal tax rate
should be yes I can I think it should be
between seventy and seventy three
percent now I am NOT suggesting that at
five hundred thousand dollars a year in
income where the question that I have is
at what income level should a seventy
percent marginal tax rate kick in it
shouldn't be after you earn fifty
thousand dollars I don't believe it
should be after you earn a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars I don't believe
it should be once you're earning five
hundred thousand dollars I think that we
should get to 70 or seventy-three
percent of the overwhelming majority of
the research I've seen shows that if
scaled correctly topping out at 70 or
seventy-three generates the most
government revenue before you start
losing revenue because the tax is so
high that people start getting
disincentivized from work so I've seen
proposals that kick in the seventy
percent at a million dollars a year of
income I've seen proposals that do it at
two million dollars a year of income or
five million dollars a year of income or
ten million dollars a year of income
maybe ten millions too high that really
is a very small percentage of the
population but there are two things to
keep in mind one
it's the marginal tax rate below that
level of income wherever you said it you
are paying a lower rate and number two
there should be more rates between our
current top rate I believe the current
top rate is thirty seven percent there
needs to be more between 37 and seventy
if that were to be kicked in so it would
be graduated you might go okay I think
right now 420 or 480 maybe is where 37%
kicks in then you might go to 45 between
480 and 750 or a million then you might
go to 52 between a million and two
million it's got a scale and those are
the models that generate the most
government revenue and they are not so
oppressive that they start to
disincentivize work in a way that will
be problematic for the economy a lot of
research on this I'm all
to having my mind changed on it now
there's other questions that are
ancillary to this that are important
ones like for example should capital
gains be taxed at that same rate right
now there's a lot of very wealthy people
who if they were to pay income tax as as
earned income as wages would be paying
37% but because they are receiving a lot
of this income through capital gains
whether it's dividends or other sorts of
capital gains selling stocks that
they've made money on they are taxed at
the lower capital gains rate so one idea
that is often mentioned is in order to
eliminate that you really need to raise
the capital gains rate to simply be what
the Earned Income the the wage rate
would be personal income tax rate so
that there is no advantage to earning
the income via capital gains rather than
working for a living as some like to say
I'm open I'm open to raising I believe
capital gains should be raised but I
think you also need more levels
previously or right now I believe that
there's just two rates for capital gains
I think it should be progressive it
needs to have more tears than two and
I'm getting I'm going for memory here
I'm just riffing but I do think that
there are more delicate considerations
when you raise capital gains I think it
should be done but I think we need to
understand that it is not the same as
raising taxes on wages but to go back to
the beginning
I believe the top marginal tax rate
should be seventy percent the debate is
at what level of income should that rate
kick in and I want to hear from you on
this issue we've got a fantastic bonus
show coming up for you today
what is the bonus show well every day we
do an hour show that show is available
to everybody it goes out on the radio it
goes out on TV it's the free podcast it
gets chopped up and uploaded to YouTube
as video clips but there is another show
that we do every day it's called the
bonus show and you can get access to it
two ways you can become a member at join
pakman.com it's very cheap its support
the work we do and you get instant
access to the bonus show or you can go
to patreon.com/scishow and make a pledge
of at least five dollars a month from
five dollars and up you get access to
the bonus show and then you will be able
to join us as a producer Pat will also
be doing on the bonus show Pat now also
hosting the Friday bonus show himself
much to the pleasure and dismay of
different people in the audience Pat
will talk to you very very shortly